aquí en ucrania el frente de batalla se
encuentra ahora mismo en el donbass en
la zona de dones y lugares donde el
ejército ruso está intentando cercar a
las tropas ucranianas que resisten de
momento pero la mayor intensidad de las
batallas está en ese frente del donbass
también en la zona norte que conecta el
donbass con heart kids donde nos
encontramos ahora mismo esto es primera
línea de batalla están a tan sólo 40 km
se están intentando luchar por esa
carretera que conecta el donbass con
jarquín y hay informaciones encontradas
porque mientras el ministerio de defensa
ruso asegura que están tomando parte de
esa carretera en el ejército de
ucraniano aqui en kharkiv lo que dice es
que hay una batalla en marcha y que
ellos controlan hasta la ciudad de zoom
lo que hemos podido comprobar nosotras
sobre el terreno es que en efecto esa
carretera está mayoritariamente
controlada por el ejército ucraniano y
los misiles siguen cayendo a esta ciudad
no hay un lugar seguro aquí en jarquín
porque hemos sido testigos también de
este lanzamiento de misiles contra
objetivos civiles contra un parque donde
una mujer una
que estaba paseando fue herida
gravemente la situación es bastante
complicada en esta ciudad porque también
preocupa la zona norte donde está el
barrio de santis acá allí hay una crisis
humanitaria
bastante aguda hace falta medicinas agua
a los ciudadanos sobreviven como pueden
y están preocupados porque en esa
frontera con rusia se están acumulando
tropas rusas y se espera una ofensiva
que todavía no tienen información de
cuándo se producirá